thanks jillian beauty and lifestyle
advisor don mccarthy is sharing some
winter health wellness tips and must
have for the season take a look
hello las vegas health and wellness is
not just important for us but for our
fur kids too and these kitty cafe and
doggy diner floating pet bowls will help
you elevate your pet's life while making
your life as a pet parent easier too
why elevate your pet's bowl well this
will help aid in your pet's digestion
you don't eat with your chin to your
chest and neither should your dog or cat
another bonus these are dishwasher safe
easy to install great colors and your
floor vacuum won't knock over your pet
bowls anymore
all of the catio and doggio product
lines are proudly designed and made
right here in the usa and their products
and packaging are both recyclable so
elevate your kitty or doggy's bowl today
at patiodogio.com
and that's catio with a k not a c
and my dog josie gives this to paws up
next i have the picture perfect book for
young readers who may have type 1
diabetes or know someone who does
teddy talks a positive story about type
1 diabetes written by a mom who is a
type 1 diabetic author vanessa messenger
who wanted to write a story that shed
light on a common but underrepresented
condition
knowing how challenging it can be to
explain diabetes to kids the author
incorporated her dog into the story the
real life tick-tock famous teddy who
cleverly participates in the tasks that
his human must perform to stay healthy
such as eating veggies taking medication
and checking her insulin monitor this
book will show kids with and without
diabetes that love acceptance and
excitement are possible for everyone and
that health conditions do not define
someone's life
go to messengerpublishingbooks.com
to order yours today
now like most i kicked off the year
committed to living healthier eating
better and working out however i also
love to travel and that sometimes can
derail my progress but i have found the
perfect destination the westin resort
and spa in puerto vallarta it's a
beachfront wellness resort perfect for
the whole family
located just a five minute drive from
the airport travelers will enjoy its
pristine and lush grounds
unmatched ocean views from balcony rooms
two sparkling pools with swim up bars a
private beach with kayaks and paddle
boards
signature restaurants with healthy
eating options a full service spa
fitness center with tennis court daily
fitness activities complementary bike
rentals and unbeatable rates at 189
dollars per night per person so who is
going with me in march to book your
visit go to westincuetevata.com
and lastly the new year is the perfect
time to take small steps towards feeling
even more optimistic and healthy with a
cup of tea
twining's brand new super blends
collections makes it simple to
incorporate vibrancy and wellness into
your everyday routine with delicious
functional sleep
immune support
energy and heart tea to nourish the mind
body and soul i personally love tea and
these are available nationwide or just
go to twiningsusa.com
for more information on any of these
product side features or destinations
just go to dawnscorner.com and i will
connect you to all of their websites
happy new year see you next month